monsieur le président à main prêt à
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
membres du gouvernement mes chers
collègues je voudrais à mon tour saluer
votre nomination à tête du gouvernement
mais la première ministre et vous
apprécieront de les collègues du groupe
rdse et à mon nom propre nos meilleurs
voeux de pleine réussite nous avons
votre tâche s'annonce ardue mais notre
pays concitoyens méritent et que vous
trouviez la voie du succès car c'est un
fait incontestable que nous nous situons
bien un moment charnière de notre
histoire collective dans les causes
remonte à plusieurs décennies
assumant notre histoire dans toute sa
complexité ses épisodes glorieux comme
les plus seulement un montant minimal
ici l avenir propre est en profonde
mutation économique et social qui revend
de tant de richesses mais qui ne sait
plus quelle est sa place dans une
économie mondialisée dans les salles de
décisions ça ne lui échappe et nous
constatons parfois une puissance de
l'innovation se dessine de plus en plus
à en europe quand industrie recule
inexorablement ou que notre influence
culturelle s'amenuisent pour tout dire
c'est la définition même de notre
souveraineté qui sommes mises en balade
mais quoi de plus normal dans un monde
désormais multipolaire pauvre part nous
sommes pas de ceux qui se lamentent sur
un déclin irréversible de la france
englué dans des passions tristes du
nostalgie un névrosé nous croyons au
contraire aux vertus de l'action du
progrès et des scellés collective notre
peuple comme à chaque fois qui est
confronté à des choix difficiles oui
nous allons tracer des années difficiles
qui ont durement éprouvé les esprits et
les corps série d'attentats terroristes
cris veillée jaune panne et milko idée
aujourd'hui au tour de l'ain ratio dans
toutes ses réponses la société aurait pu
basculer dans l'irrationnel et se
divisent les infractions
irréconciliables tel n'a pas été le cas
même si l extrême ont su capitaliser sur
toutes les peurs pour avancer leurs
pions mortifère et pousser leur avantage
au risque tout dire et la violence
politique symbolique
voire voire physique scrutin après
scrutin l'abstention sa racine chaque
fois
nous déplorons et passera à l'avoir
compris et cause pour mieux en tirer les
leçons mais à chaque fois l'abstention
progress déplaçant les contestations de
lyon à la rue avec une montée en
puissance de la violence or nous devons
et à y mettre un terme d'abord un rôdeur
il lui est à le porter à l'unité
nationale qui a été trop souvent
galvaudé ces dernières décennies les
inégalités économiques et sociales
nourrissent-ils citoyenne était à
plusieurs vitesses qui n'est plus
acceptable et qui conduisent à le pire
des cas au séparatisme au contraire
notre société a besoin d'apaisement et
de dialogue de faire sentir à chacun
quel que soit son parcours qui fait
pleinement partie de la nation et que sa
voix pèsera pour cela nous conseillons
qu'il faut encourager le débat sous
toutes ses formes revitaliser le corps n
2 les corps intermédiaires mieux
conjuguer démocratie représentative et
expression directe nous appelons à un
véritable sursaut de la conception de la
citoyenneté dans le prolongement des
propositions concrètes de notre collègue
henri cabanel il ya urgence à recréer
les conditions de destinée commune est
de redonner aux jeunes
la ville l'a lui de s'engager pour
l'intérêt général ni à moins tout ça
restera vain seixo nationale n'est pas
érigée au rang de priorité absolue en
particulier au moment où le rationalisme
remis en cause de l'angoissé au lierse
alisme ne va plus de soi la laïcité à
l'école est violemment contesté mais
aussi aux nous reculons dans les
classements internationaux
au pays de voltaire de pasteur et alors
que nous nous allons ronde d'une
nouvelle médaille fields le travail à
accomplir est considérable
pour que les jeunes soient demain des
citoyens éclairés à cette crise la
démocratie s'ajoute une crise économique
et sociale dans les îles et jaunes n'ont
été que la phase la plus exacerbée par
les excès se sont exclus et des
préoccupations légitimes celle d'une
partie de la population qui se sent
aujourd'hui à l'écart de la
mondialisation heureuse
oublier l'état à versailles ce public de
moins en moins présent et wc de la
croissance avec une dizaine de
désindustrialisation massive et peu
d'espoir mobilité sociale victimes de la
fracture numérique
à l'heure où la dématérialisation de
masse même si les choses à lyon je passe
aussi à nos concitoyens de la ruralité
qui n'ont évidemment pas les mêmes
facilités d'accès que dans les zones
urbaines ont mobilité dite douce et
écologique mais cela ne signifie pas
qu'il soit resté à l'écologie mais trop
souvent ils ont le sentiment d'être pris
de haut à propos de la mode de vie la
transition écologique ne fonctionnera
pas si elle ne se fait pas contre contre
de nos concitoyens dans une visite
logique purement punitive non région y
sommes évidemment et attendant beaucoup
d'animation de la radical dominique
faure comme secrétaire d'état à la
ruralité pour succéder à l'excellent
jouer jo la ruralité n'est pas une
charge mais une chance pour la france
la question du pouvoir d'achat d'autres
évidemment être au coeur des priorités
du gouvernement
l'explosion du coût et matières
premières affecte d'abord les plus
fragiles dans leur consommation de
première nécessité l'annoncé du
président frappe du roi notre modèle
économique qui pénalise aux
collectivités territoriales des
solutions pérennes doivent être trouvé
conciliant impératifs écologiques et
soutenabilité financière
marc briand ministre toutes les
démocraties libérales sont aujourd'hui
confrontés à cette crise protéiforme qui
revient comme acquis parfois séculaires
l'absence de majorité claire ne signifie
pas pour autant
immobilisme et blocages nous allons
sages de la socialité mon groupe dans
toute sa diversité est disposée à
travailler à vos côtés sans esprit
partisan ni idéologique mais toujours en
faveur de l'intérêt général de nos
concitoyens et de collectivités et nous
saluons dans votre discours de politique
générale les annonces en matière de déco
égalisation de la hache que nous avions
soutenu et la renonciation des nerfs
c'est dans cet esprit constructif mouais
reposer si sts est attaché à l'ordre
puisqu'elle grande travailler à nos
propositions de lois comme celle varika
vanel sur la citoyenneté natale hydrate
sur la protection pénale des cellules et
rigole sa ville et ferroviaires jallieu
roeck son instruction des documents
d'urbanisme officiant bihac proposant un
contrat solidaire d'utilité républicaine
nous aurons d'autres propositions à
soumettre pour le territoire et vous
connaissez d'entre eux attachement à la
décentralisation
vous savez dire et par là des choix d
intérêt général nous restons
viscéralement attaché
entre liberté de vote liberté de voir
d'autres groupes que beaucoup ici nous à
lui mais en secret dans tous les cas
nous nous réjouissons de voir que senna
trouve aujourd'hui une place
particulièrement dans le jeu et le place
particulière dans le jeu institutionnel
ça serait parti à les vertus de la
modération autant réussi à n'en pas
douter des interlocuteurs exigeant mais
empreint d'une salle de la brique à
rebours des vexé des populistes de tous
bords encore un cidre et par lendemain
d'élections qui chantent mais qui
couvriront assez tôt qu'être un
parlementaire exige responsabilités et
gravité avoir nist de données avec
d'autres gouvernements des gages de
bonne volonté alors rassemblés à notre
sénat plus que jamais charmont et
territoires et des collectivités
pour le gros plus indépendante
[Musique]